we had this uh big announcement
yesterday about producer Louis leaving
and changes on the show we also said hi
to jason shepherd here our new producer
who participated and the feedback
started coming in Fast and Furious there
were a lot of suggestions about places
Lewis should move to we're still
collecting those suggestions and we'll
deal with that on Thursday with you
Louis but we had the first comment come
in about producer Jason Shepherd and it
fit the mold of so many comments about
us in two ways number one it referred to
sexual orientation and homosexuality and
number two it included a bizarre
misspelling so immediately and we'll put
this up on the screen for you to take a
look someone writing in Jason but
spelling it jasa n which is unusual
usually people look not as well Jason
Jason is sexy and has a gay name so
there is that uh and of course I have no
idea uh what a gay name even means I
have no idea how someone could think
that the name is Jay asin but what is
important about this jason and i'll give
you a chance to comment on this and get
your reaction uh is that it follows the
theme of just about every comment that
we get on the program so i don't know if
you were surprised or shocked or
appalled when you saw that but um
welcome I think it's just more of the
theme of you know we are living in the
modern day uh version of the movie
idiocracy where everyone that's
intelligent is definitely gay and that
we have ridiculous tyrant running for
president and carroll fruit cuz we can't
figure out what water our crops and yeah
just business as usual here but why is
sexual orientation so important to so
many people in our audience is louis gay
is david gay are they in a relationship
together one of our first major comments
solely about Rachel Gordon co-host an
associate producer Rachel Gordon was
someone emailing in saying as attractive
as they find her they don't know if
she's transgender but they still would
like her if she were I me did this
obsession right with the sexual
orientation and gender of people on the
show I don't fully get it uh well there
are those who because we are straight
allies uh
they would if we were gay it would mean
that our commentary on gay issues is is
not legitimate because we're gay right
kind of like how you can't comment on
anything is Israeli related because
you're Jewish which is amazing because
if you say to someone well aren't you
biased about the issue of gay rights
because you're straight I mean being
straight would make you just as biased
about an issue as not being straight in
the sense that you're bringing in your
own identity into it and you all know if
you've been listening or watching
listening to our watching the show for
any amount of time I don't subscribe to
the identity Pollock's politics idea
we're depending on what categories you
personally fit into you are either able
to or not able to legitimately comment
on any particular issue I don't
subscribe to that but that seems to keep
coming up in in a lot of uh stories so
anyway there's a comment about jason or
jason as some people seem to be spelling
it also i mentioned yesterday that US
segment producer john is working on a
compilation video uh about Louis with
some of Louis's greatest hits we also
would love it if you want to record
yourself with some kind of a message to
Louis to be included in this compilation
video either upload it to YouTube as an
unlisted video and send us the link or
just take a video on your phone and send
it to me in an email david at david
pakman.com we may get some interesting
submissions from people that we could
include some kind of parting words of
wisdom or whatever to Louis that sounds
great that sounds fine even if you hate
me and you want to say something
terrible especially yeah I don't see any
problem with that we'd love to air that
too that has been a common theme for
everyone here on the show patriotism is
alive and well absolutely so get those
to me ideally within the next four or
five days because we do wanna there's a
lot going into this incredible
compilation video so get those to me